hi there how are you good how are you
i am very well and i absolutely loved
this movie i thought it was
just incredible to watch but the
fighting is amazing it's beautiful it's
graceful it's gorgeous it's all of those
things so thank you
thank you
i'm glad you like it i'm curious in the
very beginning how much did you know
about this did you even know that you
were actually auditioning for this
project
um actually i have a funnier story
because i i didn't audition for this
part it was offered to me but i almost
didn't get it because i was on my
honeymoon in antarctica and i was out of
reach and um
so
it took them a while to find me
um but when i received the offer i was
very very gladly surprised
yeah that's certainly a place that
people i would imagine have a very hard
time finding people in right exactly
well once you did know what the
character was
what did you think of her what were you
most excited about with her once you
knew you'd actually get to play this
role
initially i really didn't know what i
signed up for because you know they were
so secretive about it
so when i arrived for training i still
didn't know much about my character
and i just kind of like stepped into
training um from day one
and i knew i had to do a lot of physical
action but i didn't know exactly what
and
until they showed me one of the scenes
and one of the most
important scenes for my character the
the long fight scene that you would see
in the beginning of the film um and they
shot that scene before we even arrived
for training so i was able to see the
whole scene in its entire kind of like
glory with all the special effects and
everything
um
with the stun team so i then i
immediately i fell in love with the
character because she is so
strong but at the same time nurturing
and loving
and uh you know the this scene with her
husband wenwoo
it was just such a
beautiful romantic story
um that i just was really really excited
about and to play you know
against uh tony lung was also like a
dream come true so
yeah i i was super excited going to
training
what does it mean to you to be a part of
this project what do you hope it'll
represent for audiences and what kind of
excitement are you hearing from your own
family and friends
my own family um
they actually
they like a lot of asian parents like
they they're like we don't know if it's
good till we see it we don't know if
you're good till we actually see it so
they haven't seen the film so they're
kind of like you know a little bit like
sitting back and waiting for it um but
when they heard you know i had to
explain to them
how big you know a marvel film is and
how important it is to
uh to have of you know a asian
lead film in the marvel universe and you
know for the world to see
and then my parents you know finally
understood how big of a film this is and
and then my dad really got excited over
my little figures um so he asked me to
like buy like dozens of them and i had
to sign all of them and my dad took all
of them and he's he's like literally
right now like distributing among our
relatives friends and everybody so i
guess in that sense like i think they're
really excited about it but um they
haven't they usually never praised me
for anything i've done
right or but like good um so
uh i did so i'm not expecting
compliments coming from their way but
yeah you know if my parents say no not
bad and that's pretty good then i i
think it's the biggest um compliment in
the world
that's awesome
well what what did you most enjoy about
the fighting style that you got to do in
the training that you did for this and
what was the biggest challenge in
how you had to approach that
um from the physical aspect of things i
think
i really enjoyed tai chi i fell in love
with tai chi which inspired my
character's fighting style um because
tai chi is
not super masculine it's not super like
you know pushing and strong but it's has
so much power in its um
movements and it's so smooth and it's
so subtle
it takes years of training to even like
understand you know how to balance every
move it's constantly in motion
it's beautiful to watch i got obsessed
with it and i was just like on youtube
all the time watching different tai chi
competitions and different
demonstrations um
but yeah and i really loved
being
flying around in air
on a wire
and that was like my first time in a
lollipop
you know twirling in the air 360
learning how to flip and doing all that
but also i had i was
lucky enough to work with the stunt team
and my stunt double who took on some of
the most dangerous movements that i
could do myself so um shout out to a
snow snow fan that's her name
um
just to like help me to complete all of
my uh movements
but yeah it was definitely a great
learning opportunity for me to fall in
love with tai chi
but i and i think you know with the
magic of marvel
movie magic that elevated our movements
and the scenes um yeah it's just
visually stunning to
watch obviously some of these fight
scenes are so graceful and beautiful do
they feel like that when you're shooting
them do you have mishaps or awkward
moments happening
oh yeah all the time uh
it it feels and i i was imagining
something similar to this but you know i
i could never imagine what it looked
like fully when you know after they've
done all the editing and everything but
um yeah there were times where i just
like
wasn't sure like if i was doing it right
because the tai chi movement is so
how do i describe it it's so precise but
it also requires you to be so free in
your form that you don't have to think
about it you know you can't look like
you're thinking about it has become so
natural you know so finding that balance
and to like you know
i'm an actor after all i'm not a you
know i'm not a martial artist so like to
really like focus on the acting part of
it as well it was a lot to to juggle but
um
yeah i think with multiple takes and you
know trial and error and um having the
best support and destin really letting
us to freely try different things and
and all of that i'm glad it came out
really beautifully
you started your career as a film and tv
actor in asia before
going to juilliard and now you're
working in hollywood productions so what
what most surprised you about being on a
set like this
just how big everything is on this set i
mean i've been
to quite big sets but you know just how
many people
are working on set and behind the scenes
um i think the fans like you you just
don't know like there's literally
hundreds of people on set um it's like
an army of people trying to make you
know such an you know even scenes with
you know just you see two actors on
screen
there's just so many moving parts um
that was happening behind the scenes um
and i was just in awe of you know
the producers who can put you know such
great team together
um and yeah and then i it was kind of my
first time stepping back onto a film set
after five years of
not working in front of the screen i was
in school doing theater
um just stepping back it feels
it felt very familiar at the same time
really fresh and new
um it was incredible feeling
there's beautiful themes of family in
this what did you most love about that
aspect of the story
um i'm incredibly close to my family and
i
think family is such an important um
um
thing in in asian culture especially um
so i think this film really like spoke
to me personally but i think
hopefully the audience will resonate
with that as well not only you know
asian audiences but also
um audiences from all over the world
that they can everyone anyone can relate
to
um you know the love the unconditional
love that you share
among a family you know between family
members and um and the fact that they
know no family is perfect
we all have our differences
misunderstandings up and downs and i i
think i hope people can see that you
know
we are who we are because of our family
because of our ancestry
and and respect that and um and i think
given what's happening to especially our
elders um older asian
um
people in america
um
i feel like i hope the world understand
how much we value our
our older generations our parents our
grandparents who
who worked so hard and sacrificed so
much for us
the new generation
that i hope people respect them more and
give them peace and you know the respect
that they deserve
well thank you so much for talking about
this beautiful work in the film thank
you
thank you